hello and welcome everyone to yet
another exciting session from simply
learn
they call it the patterns they call it
the pyramids
they call it with the name of a
geometrical shape as well
yes this is definitely that one question
that brings goosebumps to all those who
enter
into an interview hall today's session
is exactly about the same
the pattern programs in java we will
discuss
all the most frequently asked questions
in the interviews
based on the pattern programs and java
now before we begin
how about you subscribe to the simply
learn youtube channel and hit the bell
icon
so that you can stay updated with all
the tech information that you need
related to the current id and upscale
yourself based on
latest industry level standards now
let's quickly begin with our session
first of all
we will discuss the right angle triangle
pattern
so basically the right angle triangle
star pattern
looks something like this as it is shown
on my screen
so to resolve this problem statement and
print the pattern
we must assume that this particular star
arrangement
is made in the form of a matrix where
the first row has
single star and the second row has two
stars
third row has three stars and so on now
to execute this particular code
we might need two for loops so the first
for loop
will be for printing the rows and the
second one will be for printing the
columns
now let us execute a practical program
and see how does it work
don't worry about the codes that we will
be executing here because
i have formatted a draft about all the
codes that i will be executing today and
that particular file will be attached in
the description box below
on my screen you can see the particular
pattern which is a right angle
triangle star pattern so as discussed
before
we will have the first outer for loop
which will be for printing the rows
so inside the outer for loop we have the
second for loop which we will be using
for printing the columns you can see i
have defined
the row value as 5 which means we will
be printing
the star pattern for 5 rows and we have
used a counter variable which is i
which is assigned the value of 1 and the
comparator operator is used here which
is i should be
less than or equal to the number of rows
declared
and followed by that we have a
pre-increment operator
and once the condition is true the
control will be entered into the second
for loop
where we have the next counter variable
which is j
so we have assigned j is equals to 1 and
the comparator operator which is
j should be less than or equal to i
which is the value here which is in the
outer for loop
and followed by that we have the
pre-increment operator
once the condition is true the control
will enter into the inside for loop and
will print
a star so here just let us assume that
the value of i is 1
and the statement is true so the control
will enter into the
second for loop and it will see the
conditional operator here
so j is less than or equal to i
so value of 1 is less than or equal to 1
and the star will be printed after that
we have the pre-increment operator so
here
the j value will be incremented to 2.
now if we compare the values 2 is
not less than or not equal to
1 so the condition fails here
so it will not print a star again it
will come out of the inner for loop and
it will see the next statement
which says it should print in the next
line whereas in the inside for loop you
can see we just used
print not print in the new line
so it will come to the new line and go
back to the for loop again
and the increment of i will be taking
place and
the same runs again now let us try to
execute this program and see the output
so you can see that the program got
successfully executed and the right
angle triangle
star pattern is print successfully now
let us go into the next type of program
so the next type of program is the
inverted
right angle triangle star pattern so
similarly
according to the previous example we
also consider
this one in the form of a matrix so
you can see that in the first row we
have
five stars in the second row we have
four stars
similarly so on now let us try to check
out the code
and learn how does it work and how to
print the star pattern
on a screen we are back in the practical
mode again
so the kind of pattern that we wanted to
print as
this one which is a little bit similar
to the previous one but only thing that
is inverted
so the code is pretty much the same but
the only changes that we need to do
are related to the comparator operator
in the previous example we chose that i
should be less than
or equal to 1 and in the next stage we
used
pre-increment operator in here we are
using
a different one which is pre-decrement
and inside the for loop we have the j
comparator operator in the same way so
here we have declared the row value as 5
and inside the for loop
we will equate the counter variable
equals to rows which is 5
and followed by that the comparator
operator compares if the value of phi
is greater than or equal to 1 and
followed by that
we will use the predicament operator
once the condition is true
the control will enter into the inside
follow and here
the counter variable j is assigned to
the value 1 and the condition
is j should be less than or equal to
i and followed by that we have the
pre increment operator which is plus
plus
j so once the condition is true it will
print
the value of a star and followed by that
it will again continue the loop so here
the follow
will work in the following way and i is
equals to 5
i is greater than or equal to 1 which is
true
and pre-decrement so the condition is
true so the control will enter into the
inside for loop where it will again
compare with value of j j is equals to 1
and
j is less than or equal to 5 and
followed by that
we have the post increment so the
control will enter inside the for loop
and print
a star and followed by that in the next
instance
the value of j will be incremented to 2.
so 2 is less than or equal to i
followed by that pre-increment and
in the next iteration it will print a
star
again so this will continue until the
condition is true
once the condition fails the control
will exit the follow
and print in the next line you can see
that we have print in the new line
here which is unlike the print function
which is inside the for loop
so this will continue until the
statements
are true now let us try to execute this
program and see if the desired pattern
will be printing or not
there you can see that the program got
successfully executed
and the pattern which we desired for is
printed on the screen
now let us move ahead into the next type
of pattern
so the next type of pattern is the arrow
shaped
pattern and this almost looks familiar
to the previous two programs
the only difference is we have combined
them together to form an arrow pattern
now let us try to combine the previous
two programs and print this
so now you can see on my screen we have
our desired pattern
which looks like an arrow so as
discussed before
we are trying to combine the two
programs that we executed before
so the first half of the program is
designed
for the first half of the pattern which
is completely similar
to our first program so the second half
of the pattern
is from our second program but the only
difference here is
we have considered the value of rows
is row minus 1 because we don't want
another extra row to be printing here
in this way so you can see if we used i
value is equals to rows
then the pattern would be something like
this we will not have a pointed edge
so to get a pointed edge we will use rho
minus 1 to get this pattern what we
desired for
now let us try to execute this program
and print the output
now let us enter the number of rows we
want let's enter five
so there you go let me expand my output
screen
yeah there you go we have the pattern
which we desired for
and don't forget that we need to use row
minus 1
in the next stage which is the second
half of the program
so this is how the arrow pattern is
printed now let us move further
and see the next type of pattern in our
list so in the next pattern we have
the right angle triangle which is
completely similar to the first one
but the hypotenuse is on the other side
as you can see this is the difference
between the first program and
this program so in the first program we
had the hypotenuse in this direction
and now we have the hypotenuse in the
opposite direction
now similarly to the first program we
shall consider this one
as well in the form of a matrix so you
can see
if we consider this pattern in the form
of a matrix we have
four spaces followed by a star
similarly in the second row we have
three spaces
followed by two stars in the third one
we have two spaces
and three stars and so on so
the main point that we need to consider
here is
first we need to print the spaces
followed by that
we need to print the stars to get this
pattern
now let us execute a practical program
and see the output
so back in the practical mode you can
see on my screen
the desired pattern what we are looking
for is this
so here the only difference is
we have to print the spaces first so for
printing the spaces we will be using
this folder
with the condition j is equals to 2 into
n
minus i and j should be greater than or
equals to 0
and j decrement which is a post
decrement operator
so what is the value of n n is nothing
but the value of
rows so the value of n is declared in
the main function
and n is equals to 5 after that we will
be calling the print stars
function which is over here and the
value of n will be carried over here
and then the counter variables i and j
will take care of the for loops
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
so you can see that the program is
successfully executed
and the desired pattern is printed
successfully
so this for loop will be run until the
condition is true
once this for loop fails we will enter
into the next for loop
which is particularly designed to print
the stars
now after this let us move ahead into
our next type of
pattern so the next type of pattern
is an inverted right angle triangle
pattern
which is opposite to the second type of
program that we dealt with
now similarly let us consider this in
the same way as we considered all the
other programs
that is in the form of a matrix so here
we have five stars in the first row four
stars in the next one and
one space followed by that we have two
spaces followed by that we have the
three stars
and three spaces two stars and so on
now let us see a practical program and
try to print this particular pattern
so we are back in the practical mode so
you can see that
the desired star pattern is this and it
is completely similar to our previous
pattern
so the only difference is we tried to
print spaces
first in the earlier pattern and here we
are trying to print the stars first
so that's the only difference and we
have the
same for loops so the first for loop is
for rows
and it will print spaces and the second
follow is for stars which will print
the stars as you can see we have the row
values
and the column values here as the
comparator operator
and we have the comparator operator
which finds if j
is greater than i in the first case
the loop will fail because the value of
j and i are completely similar because
we have declared i is equals to rows in
the first outer for loop
and same j is equals to rows in the
second inner for loop
so obviously the condition has to fail
and it will not
print any space here it will directly
enter into the next
for loop and will print the star pattern
and followed by that
we will enter into the next line
so this follow-up will print the number
of stars in the first row
according to the row number for example
if we give 5 as the row number then it
will
print 5 stars in the first row and it
will exit the for loop and
it will enter into the next line and the
same pattern will be continued
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
now let us give 5 as the number of rows
needed
so there you go you can see the star
pattern here
so this is how this particular star
pattern
will be generated now let us move
further and check out the next type of
pattern program in our list so the next
type of pattern program
in our list is arrow so this arrow is
completely similar to the previous one
the only difference is it is in the
inverted way
which is it has pointed towards the left
side
now let us check out the practical
program and learn how to execute this
back on to eclipse ide so you can find
some similarities between the previous
two programs and this particular program
in the previous two programs we tried to
print the first half
of the pattern and followed by that we
have printed
the second half of the pattern now we
are going to just
combine both the programs and print this
particular
arrow pattern
so here the first half of this
particular program
is concerned with the top portion of
this pattern
which is the right angle triangle
followed by that
the second half of the program where we
have
the conditions placed so this particular
segment of the code takes care about the
second
half of the program which is the
inverted right angle triangle
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
so let us specify the number of rows as
five completely similar to the previous
two programs
now let's press enter now there you go
let me expand my
console so there you go you can see the
arrow pattern so this is how you
print an arrow pattern pointing towards
the left side
we have also discussed a narrow pattern
where the arrow will be pointing towards
the right side
as the program number three
again don't worry about the codes all
the programs that i'm going to execute
in this session
are drafted in the form of a text
document and that
is linked in the description box below
you can take that source file and
practice the programs for yourself
no worry now let's move ahead and check
out the next type of program
so the next type of pattern that we have
in our list
is the pyramid we also call this an
acute angled
triangle star pattern
now let us understand the logic for this
now you can see without the matrix
format this looks completely similar to
our first
program but only the difference is we
have a space
which is obvious but there is a small
difference
let us check out what the difference is
if we look this program in the form of a
matrix
you can see there are variations in
spaces
in the first row we have two spaces one
star
followed by that again two spaces in the
next row we have
alternate space and star space
and star and similarly in the third row
we have a star
space star and space so this is how the
matrix continues according to the number
of
rows provided so let us understand how
the logic exactly works for this program
okay so you can see the pattern
that we desired is in the form of an
acute angle triangle
or pyramid now we have two counter
variables which is i is equals to 0
in the outer for loop and j is equals to
n
minus 1 which is inside the for loop so
the value of
n is equals to phi which is the total
number of rows that we needed in a
particular pattern
now you can see in the outer for loop we
have the condition
which is i should be less than n
so i should be less than the number of
rows which is equals to
five followed by that we have the post
increment operator
i plus plus so the condition will be
true because 0 is less than 5 and it
will enter into the inside for loop
where we have
j which is equals to 5 minus
0 followed by that we have the condition
so 5 is greater than
1 so the resultant of this particular
statement is 5
so 5 which is now the value of j is
greater than
followed by that we have the post
decrement operator which will decrease
the value of
j in every iteration so once the
statement is true
it will try to print a space
so it will print the spaces until the
condition is true
so once the first for loop fails
the control will enter into the next
following for loop
where we have j is equals to 0 and j
should be
less than or equal to the value of i
which is currently equals to 0
and followed by the conditional
statement we have
the post increment operator which is j
plus plus
so this particular for loop is used for
printing
two things which is the first one star
followed by that we have a space so once
this follow
gets executed the control will exit it
and will print in the new line
so this is how the program works now let
us try to execute this program and see
the odd
there you go the program got
successfully executed and the required
spaces and the stars have been printed
here
so as you can see we have spaces
followed by that we have a star
similarly space
space is on to the left a star and the
second star
so followed by the previous program we
have the next
program which is also considered to be
like
a pyramid but the only difference is it
is in an inverted format now let us
check out the logic behind this program
and try to execute a practical program
so logic wise it's completely similar to
the previous one
we have star followed by that we have a
space
and again a star space and a star
next row we have alternate space and
star
and finally we have two spaces
star and two spaces so the number of
spaces and stars is
based upon the number of rows we provide
now let us try to execute a program and
see the output
don't worry this is completely similar
to the previous one but the only
difference is
it is printed in the inverted fashion so
there will be
minor changes to the code let's try to
look on those changes
so here we are back in eclipse so the
desired pattern is
here which is an inverted pyramid and
the previum program was a regular
pyramid
so here is the logic and we have the
following for loops
so the first for loop is dedicated for
printing the number of spaces we require
so inside the exterior follow we have
the counter variable i
is equals to 0 and i should be less than
or equals to the number of rows minus 1
and followed by that we have the post
increment operator
i plus plus so let us assume that we
have provided the number of rows to be
5 and according to the logic i is equals
to 0 and followed by that
0 is less than or equals to 5 minus 1
which is 4
and followed by that we have the post
increment operator which will increment
the value of i
to 1 once after the for loop first
iteration is finished
so once the exterior follow condition is
true
the control will enter into the second
for loop which is the internal follow
and we have the second counter variable
which is j is equals to 0
followed by that the comparator operator
which says
j should be either less than or equal to
the value of i
followed by that we have the post
increment operator on j
so this particular code segment or the
first
part of the program takes care about the
number of spaces we require in our
pattern followed by that we have the
second for loop
which will take care of the number of
stars we print
and the number of spaces we require
after the star pattern
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
now let us provide the number of rows we
need let's provide the
value as 5. now there you go according
to the
logic provided in the program the star
patterns are successfully generated
followed by the spaces
now moving ahead we have the next type
of pattern
which is the combination of first and
second pyramids
now let us understand the logic and
print this pattern
now you can see the desired pattern is
the combination of the first pyramid and
the second pyramid
so the first half of the program is
derived from the first pyramid pattern
and the second part of the program
is derived from the second pyramid
pattern now we have combined them
together and now we are trying to print
the rhombus pattern
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
let us provide the number of rows as
five
and there you go so here you can see the
desired star pattern has been
successfully executed
so according to the input we have the
first five rows
and followed by that we have the
inverted star pattern
where we avoided the first row and
printed the following four rows
so that we have a proper rubik's pattern
now moving ahead we shall
see the next type of pattern in our list
so followed by the previous pattern we
have the next type of pattern
which looks completely similar to the
previous one
but the only difference is we have
printed the second type of pyramid first
and then the first type of pyramid which
makes it look like an hourglass
now let us understand the logic and
print this pattern
so here is the desired pattern what we
are looking for and this was the
previous pattern what we printed
now followed by the first segment we
have the second segment which is
dedicated to print the second half of
the pattern
which happens to be the first type of
pyramid which is a regular pyramid
but the only difference is inside the
first follow
we are using the rows minus one command
because
we don't want an extra star
so if we add in an extra star this
pattern will
look a little abnormal so let us try so
this is what it looks like if we had an
extra star there
so let us remove it so this is how our
pattern should look like so that's the
reason why we are using
row minus 1 here now let us try to
execute this program and see the output
now let us enter the number of rows we
want let us input 5
enter so there you go you can see the
program got successfully executed and
the desired star pattern has been
printed on the console
now let us move further and have a look
on the next type of pattern in our list
so followed by the hourglass pattern we
have the next pattern where we need to
print
a diagonal star pattern now if we look
at the logic
it's just a single line which is placed
in the form of a diagonal
now let us check the logic behind it
so you can see we have printed stars in
the form of a diagonal
of a matrix now we have the first four
spaces followed by that we have a star
and similarly
three spaces provided by a star then a
space and so on
now to print this pattern what's the
logic let's go back to eclipse and try
to print this program
so this is our desired pattern now let
us go into our
program now inside the program we have
two counter variables which are 1
i 2 is j so the first for loop
is i is equals to 1 i is less than or is
equals to 5 which is the row number
then i post increment so when the logic
is true which is one is less than or
equal to the row number five
the control will enter into the second
for loop
so once the control enters into the
outer for loop we have the second
for loop where we have our second
counter variable which is
j j is equals to 0 and j is
less than 5 minus i which is 5 minus 1
which is the current value of i
which is 4. so 0 is the value of
j currently so 0 is less than 4 followed
by that we have the
post increment on j counter variable so
once the condition is true
the control will enter into the second
inner for loop and will print
space so this loop will run until the
condition is true
once the condition fails it will come
out of the inner for loop and will print
a star in the
new line followed by that it will
continue to start the outer for loop
again
so this is how the flow goes ahead now
let's
run the program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the desired
pattern is printed
now let's move ahead and understand the
next type of pattern in our program
so the next type of pattern is a little
bit similar to the previous one
so in the previous pattern we had one
diagonal
right now we have two diagonals which
have formed the shape of x
so we can consider this as a next
pattern now let's check out the logic
and next after that let's execute the
program
so according to the logic when we
consider this particular pattern in a
form of a matrix
we have the stars printed in the first
row followed by that we have
three spaces and then again a star so
this is continued in the same way
with alternate spaces and in the third
row we have a single intersection point
with
one star so this is how the pattern
should look like once the program gets
executed
now let's check out the program and see
the output
so you can see on my output console this
was our previous pattern
now what we are going to do is make a
similar pattern
in the opposite direction and make sure
they intersect each other
now you can see our program has two
segments the first segment
and the second segment they both look a
little similar
because the first segment will print the
upper part of the pattern
that is the first v and then the second
segment will print
the lower part of the pattern which is
the inverted v
now let us check out the condition we
have the first outer loop which has
the first counter variable which is i is
equals to n
n is nothing but the number of rows that
we want in our pattern
then i should be greater than or equal
to
1 followed by that we have the post
decrement operator
where we will decrease the value of i
then
if the condition is true then the
control will enter into the next
statement
where we have the inner for loop with
second counter variable that is j is
equals to i
then the condition is j should be less
than the value of
rows provided then post increment of j
and if the condition statement is true
then it will enter into the inner for
loop and it will print
a space similarly for printing the star
we have the next segment inside the next
segment
the condition is a little trickier
because we don't want to print any stars
in the
space between the x pattern we provide
this condition
where j is equals to 1 and j should be
less than or equals to
2 times the value of i which is the auto
loop
minus 1 if this condition is true the
control will enter
inside the for loop where we have if
else condition
if j is equals to is equals to 1 or j
is equals to is equals to 2 into i minus
1
then we should print a star else we
should print a space
so this will print the upper part of the
pattern
and similarly we have another segment
which will print the lower part of the
pattern which is the
inverted v pattern now let's execute
this program and see the output
as you can see the program got executed
now let us provide the value of
n let us provide phi and there you go
you can see that the program printed the
desired pattern
so this is the first half of the pattern
which is the proper v
then this is the second half of the
program which is the inverted v
so this is what the flow of the program
is now let us move further and check out
the next
pattern in our list so the next pattern
in our list
is the inverted v pattern
now let us check out the logic behind it
if you see this in the form of a matrix
then you can recognize this
we had already discussed similar program
which was the third one
where we had printed the pyramid shape
but the only difference is
we have missed out the star in between
which makes it look like a inverted
v now let us go back to eclipse and
execute a program based on this to print
this pattern
as you can see we have our desired
pattern on my screen
which is an inverted v so if we check
out the logic
we have outside loop and inside loop
so we have two for loops so the first
outer for loop
has out is equals to one out should be
less than or equals to the number of row
size
then post increment of outside variable
if the condition is true we enter into
the inner for loop where we have
inner loop is equals to one inner loop
should be less than or equals to the row
size into two
then we have increment operator which is
a post increment
so if this particular condition is true
then we enter
into another statement where we have the
if else statement
so if in value is equal to is equals to
control
x or n is equals to print control
y then we should print star
else we should print a space now let us
try to execute this program and see the
output
now let us provide the row size which is
5 so as you can see we have got
our desired pattern now let us move
ahead and execute the next type of
pattern
which is the v pattern now let us
understand the logic behind it
it is completely similar to the previous
program but the difference is
the pattern is in inverted position to
the previous one which is in the proper
v format
so now let us try to check out the code
and execute the program
and print the pattern so on my screen
you can see the desired pattern what we
are looking for which is
v now the previous program was to print
an
inverted v so the complete program is
same
but only there is a minor change in the
logic where we have replaced
i as greater than or equal to 0
and there is some change in the second
segment as well
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the desired
pattern is printed here
the value of n or row size is equals to
5 which we have declared here in the
main part
now let us get back and check out the
next pattern to be executed in our list
so the next pattern is the combination
of both an inverted v
and a normal v which will result in the
form of a rhombus
now as you can see this is our previous
program
now we have two segments in our code
where we have the first segment to print
the starting or the top position
which is an inverted v format and the
second segment of the code
is designed to print the second half of
the pattern which is
the normal v pattern so we will combine
these two
and print the rhombus shape
now let me provide the number of rows
which is 5
so there you go you can see the desired
pattern now let us move ahead and check
out our next pattern
so the next pattern is completely
similar to one of the previous ones
which is a pyramid pattern
but the difference is this pyramid is
hollow or in other words
this looks like an acute angled triangle
now let us understand the logic behind
it so if you look at this matrix then
you can find that
we are going to print the stars in the
form of
a side of the triangle which is we will
print the stars in this
shape of a triangle and nothing inside
the matrix
now let us understand the program and
print this pattern
so as you can see the desired pattern
has been located here which is a
triangular pattern
now inside this we have three particular
for loops so the first
follow-up is the order for loop and the
rest two for loops are the internal for
loops
so the first internal for loop is
dedicated to print spaces
where we don't require stars and the
second internal for loop is dedicated to
print stars
where we require them also we have nfl's
condition
which decides where to print a star and
where not to
now if we look at the condition i should
be less than or equal to the number of
rows provided
and if the condition is true then we
enter into the internal follow
and in the internal for loop if j is
less than the number of rows given
then in that particular location we need
to print a space
once the condition in the first for loop
is failed the control will enter into
the next follow where we have the next
counter variable that is k is equals to
1
and k should be less than or equals to 2
into i minus 1
where the value of i is 1 at the current
stage
and followed by that we have the post
increment of the value of
k if k is equal to equal to 1 or i
is equal to equal to the number of nodes
or k
is equal to equal to 2 star i minus 1
then we should print a star so this will
give the location in the matrix
where we should print star to make it as
a triangle pattern
if location is anything else than the
condition provided
then we should be printing space there
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
let us provide the number of rows as 5.
so there you go we have printed the
desired pattern
so the next pattern after the triangle
pattern is the box pattern
so this particular program will be
completely similar to the previous
program the only difference is we need
to find the locations where we need to
print stars
so that the resultant pattern looks like
a box
so for that we will make some changes in
our program
and those changes will be related to the
rows and columns
now let us understand the logic so as
discussed before we need to
look at this pattern in the form of a
matrix and check out the number of
rows and columns so where the number of
row and column are equal
we need to print a star so let us now
check out the program and execute the
program to print this particular pattern
so as you can see on my screen we have
the same program that we used to print
the
triangle but now here we have rows and
columns
so n is nothing but the row and m is
nothing but the column
so if the value of the external for loop
that is i is equals to equals to 1
and i is equals to equals to the number
of rows provided
similarly j is equal to equal to 1 which
is the internal for loop counter
variable value
and if j is equal to equals to m that is
the column value
then we should print a star in that
particular location
and wherever the location does not match
we should provide a space
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
so there you go we have our desired
pattern which is the box pattern
now let us move ahead and check out the
next type of pattern in our list
so you can see the next pattern is
completely similar to our first pattern
the first pattern
was a right angled triangle now we have
the same right angle a triangle
but the only difference is we have used
numbers here
now we will use the numbers from our for
loops and we will print the same values
in our pattern so that it looks like a
right angle triangle
now let us understand the logic so we
will see this pattern in the form of a
matrix
now we will print the numbers where we
require them where we don't require the
numbers we will print
spaces now let us check out the program
and execute it to print the following
pattern
now you can see we have got back to our
same program but the only difference is
here we are using the values of the
inner
for loop which is j instead of a star
previously we used star symbol here and
we are now replacing it with
the inner follow up value let us try to
execute this program and see the output
now let us enter the number of rows as 5
and there you go
we have the values of the internal for
loop making the pattern
look like a right angle triangle pattern
now let us move further and check out on
our next type of pattern in the list
so here is another right angle triangle
in our list
but the difference is we are using the
numbers
in a continuous manner which is 1 2 3 4
5
6 to 15. this type of triangle is also
called as
floyd's triangle now let us understand
the logic
so similar to the previous one we will
consider this in the form of a matrix
and we will print the numbers only way
we require them
that is to form a right angle triangle
where we don't need the numbers we will
try to print a space there
now let us check out the program and
execute it and print this pattern
now you can see we have got back to
eclipse and don't get scared about the
pattern it's completely similar to the
previous one
only thing is we will be using one extra
counter variable which is
k so we have provided the value of k is
equals to 1
and where we are supposed to print stars
we will add the
post increment operator to the counter
variable k
so whenever the for loop gets executed
we will be printing the values of k
which is 1 2 3 4 5 and so on now let us
try to execute this program and see the
output
so there you go the values of k 1 2 3 4
5 6 7
until 15 so this is how the floyd's
triangle work
now let's get back and check out the
next pattern in our list
so the next pattern in our list is
similar to the previous one
which is pyramid so this type of pyramid
is also called as
pascal's triangle now let us check out
the logic
the logic is completely similar to the
pyramid's
logic but instead of star we are going
to use
numbers so this type of triangle is
called as
pascal's triangle and the logic is also
a little bit different from the regular
pyramid let us understand the logic
through the code
so now you can see the program on my
screen so
the logic and the for loops used are
completely similar to that of
the pyramid but only the difference is
we are going to print the value of
number so the number is firstly
initialized
as 1 followed by that we have a formula
for that
which is number is equals to number into
i minus j
divided by j plus 1 which are the values
of the counter variables of
outer for loop and in a for loop
respectively
now let's try to execute this program
and see the pattern
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the floyd's
triangle has been successfully
constructed here
now let us move ahead and check out the
next pattern in our list so the next
pattern in our list
is a box which is made up of binary
numbers
now let us understand the logic for it
first so if we look at this in the form
of a matrix we have binary numbers 1 and
0
which forms the pattern of a box now let
us check out the program
and execute the program to print this
particular pattern
so you can see on my screen we have the
program to print
that particular box type of pattern
using the binary numbers
so we have the external for loop for
rows and
the counter variable i is equals to 1
and i should be less than or equal to
the number of rows provided
once the condition is true we enter into
the external for loop
where we have the number and where we
have the condition
i modulus 2 is equals to is equals to 0
and the number is equals to 0
and inside that we have our logic to
print the binary numbers
now let us try to execute this program
and see the order
now let me place the number of rows as 5
and there you go we have our box pattern
using binary numbers
now let us get back and check the next
pattern in our list
so the next pattern is the ruby pattern
this is completely similar to our
program where we printed
the ruby pattern using the stars now
we'll use the numbers
and print that particular pattern now
the logic for this
is completely same that of the ruby
pattern we used
but the only difference is instead of a
star we'll be placing
the value of the counter variables now
let us try to execute this program and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and instead of
stars
we have printed the ruby pattern using
the numbers
now moving ahead we have our next
pattern
so here the next pattern is completely
similar to the first one which is the
right angled
triangle pattern but here instead of
numbers or stars we will be using
alphabets
so for alphabets we will be using the
ascii values in the program
let us check out that program soon now
first let's understand the logic
the logic is also completely similar to
the right angle triangle
which we followed for stars and numbers
now let's check out the program
so as you can see the desired pattern is
the right angle triangle
made out of alphabets so the logic is
completely true
but the only difference is we are going
to print characters
using ascii values and alphabet function
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
so the desired pattern is the right
angle triangle
printed using the alphabets now the
logic is completely similar to the right
angle triangle pattern
but the only difference is we are going
to use the ascii values so we have
declared an integer type variable
alphabet with the ascii value 65
which should start the alphabets from
capital a because the ascii value of
capital a
is 65. now let us run the program and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have the
right angle triangle printed using the
capital alphabet
now let's get back and check out our
next pattern
so our next pattern is a pyramid again
so instead of numbers and stars we are
going to use the alphabetical values
now let's check out the logic even here
you can see the logic is similar to the
pyramid logic now let's check out the
code and
execute the code and see the pattern now
you can even see the
logic is also similar to the pyramid
logic
but here the only difference is we are
going to use the ascii value that is 65
which is equivalent to capital a now in
the print statement
instead of a star we are going to print
the alphabets
and this particular for loop is for
spaces now let's quickly execute this
program and see the output
so there you go the pyramid pattern has
been successfully
printed so with this we have come to an
end of this particular session
if you have any queries regarding this
session or if you have any suggestions
for us
then please feel free to drop them down
in the comment section below
also if you require any code regarding
the programs that we executed in this
particular session then you can find the
document
in the description box below till then
thank you until next time
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here